.
- En attendant la livraison
d'un véhicule adapté, on se
débrouille pour rt.
Pour faciliter les déplacements
d'Édouard et Jérémie,
un ascenseur a été ajouté
dans la maison familiale.
es travaux ont permis
d'élargir les couloirs et
les portes pour que deux
fauteuils roulants puissent
ellement circuler.
Les frères de 9 et 11 ans
partagent le même gène
défectueux, celui de
la dystrophie de Duchenne.
EDOUARD FIOLA-FAUCHER
- C'est une maladie
qui fait que nos muscles
se fatiguent plus vite.- Cette e
incurable qui touche surtout
les garcons, va progresser.
L'ennemi, c'est donc
le temps qui file.
SÉBASTIEN McKENZIE-FAUCHER,
père d'Édouard et Jérémie
- Dès qu'on apprend ça,
on se rend compt...
Tu sais, on a la nouvelle
qu'on va probablement survivre
à nos enfants. Ça, c'est dur,
c'est probablement le plus dur
à apprendre dans le diagnostic.
- Depuis 7 ans, c'est une étape
à la fois. La famille
Fiola-Fauche, grande soeur et
grands-parents inclus, préfère
se concentrer sur l'aspect
pratic du quotidien.
CATHERINE FIOLA,
mèuard et Jérémie
- C'est des choses qui sont très
concrètes. C'est facile de
se concentrer sur ça puis
de s'impliquer. Probablement que
ça nous aide justement à...
je suis en train de trouver des
solutions. Je ne suis pas juste
dans : Je subis la maladie.
- Il y a des moments où
- En septembre là,...
- Ah, mon Dieu! On est encore
en septembre pour moi.
(rires)
- La rentrée à l'école,
il fallait planifier pour
Édouard le secondaire.
- Le CHU Ste-justine suit
une soixantaine de garcons
atteints de la dystrophie
de Duchenne.
Dre CAM-TU EMILIE NGUYEN,
neurologue CHU Sainte-Justine
- C'est la maladie musculaire
qu'on rencontre le plusfrequemm.
Les symptomes débutent
généralement vers l'âge de
2-3 ans avec une faiblesse
qui affecte les
particulierement les cuisses.
Donc des garçons qui vont avoir
une difficulté à se relever
du sol, à monter les escaliers.
On n'a pas encore de cure en
2021 pour la dystrophie
musculaire de Duchenne;
ce qui fait en sorte que les
garcon atteints se
retrouvent en fauteuils roulants
typiquement vers l'age de
10-12 ans.
- Ce n'est pas encore le
traitement curatif que les
pédiatres et quelque 300
familles québécoises attendent,
(images laboratoire) mais des
eurs de Ste-Justine
espèrent que la résolvine
permettra de préserver les
- On va moins capables
d'améliorer la qualité de vie
des patients, et que tout cela
va augmenter.
- Décence si inflammatoire qui
entrait de nombr
secondaires.
- Ils sont de l'ostéoporose des
gens 11 ans et on s'attend à des
problèmes de cataracte il y a
beaucoup d'enflure.
- À chaque fois qu'il y a une
étude qui sort ses un horizons
de x années on essaie de pas
trop est optimiste au regard de
l'âge de nos enfants et on nous
dit que ça restait trop fort
mais en même temps ça donne de
l'espoir aux autres parents.
- J'aimerais premier ministre.
Acteurs, réalisa
et écrivain.
- Le présent et plein de v